principalement des militaires masculins, grands, solides, forts,
et quelques femmes aussi,
d'essayer la création artistique comme psychothérapie.
Les résultats furent tout simplement spectaculaires.
Des œuvres d'art saisissantes et symboliques
sont créées par nos militaires, hommes et femmes,
et chaque pièce raconte une histoire.
Nous avons remarqué que
l'art-thérapie contourne le problème de langage avec le cerveau.
La création artistique accède
aux mêmes aires sensorielles que celles qui encodent les traumatismes.
Les militaires peuvent utiliser la création artistique
pour affronter leurs expériences de façon rassurante.
Ils peuvent ensuite associer des mots à leurs créations,
en réintégrant les hémisphères gauche et droit du cerveau.
Nous avons pu voir que cela fonctionne avec tout type d'art :
le dessin, la peinture, le collage.
Cependant, ce qui semble avoir le plus grand impact
est la fabrication de masques.
Dès lors, ces blessures ont bien plus qu'un nom,
elles ont aussi un visage.
Lorsque les militaires fabriquent ces masques,
cela leur permet de faire face à leur traumatisme.
Et c'est incroyable de voir à quel point
cela leur permet de rompre le traumatisme et de commencer à guérir.
Vous vous souvenez de VEDB ?
Il s'agissait d'une expérience réelle de l'un de mes patients.
Et lorsqu'il a créé son masque,
il a pu se détacher de cette image obsédante.
Au début, ce processus intimidait le militaire
mais il a fini par voir le VEDB comme un masque,
et non comme sa blessure interne,
et il quittait chaque séance
en me remettant le masque
et en me disant : « Melissa, prenez soin de lui. »
Un jour, nous avons placé VEDB dans une boite pour le conserver
et lorsque le militaire a quitté NICoE,
il a choisi de laisser VEDB derrière lui.
Un an plus tard, il n'avait revu VEDB qu'à deux reprises
et ces deux fois, VEDB souriait
et le militaire n'était pas anxieux.
Maintenant, lorsqu'un souvenir traumatisant le hante,
il continue de peindre.
Chaque fois qu'il peint ces images troublantes,
il les voit moins ou plus du tout.
Pendant des milliers d'années, les philosophes nous ont dit
que le pouvoir de créer
est très étroitement lié à celui de détruire.
La science nous montre que la partie du cerveau
qui enregistre une blessure traumatique
peut aussi être la partie du cerveau où la guérison se produira.
Et l'art-thérapie nous montre comment faire ce lien.
Nous avons demandé à l'un de nos militaires
de décrire comment la création de masques a influencé son traitement
et voici ce qu'il a déclaré.
[Militaire :] Vous vous évadez à travers le masque.
Vous vous évadez à travers le dessin,
et pour moi, ça a libéré le blocage
donc j'étais capable de le faire.
Et quand je l'ai regardé deux jours plus tard,
je me suis dit : « Merde alors ! C'est ça l'image, la clé, le puzzle. »
Et à partir de là, ça s'est envolé.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'à partir de là,
mon traitement a disparu,
parce qu'ils me disaient : « Kurt, explique-le, explique-le. »
Et pour la première fois en 23 ans,
j'ai enfin pu parler ouvertement de choses à n'importe qui.
Je pourrais vous en parler maintenant si je le voulais,
parce que ça s'est débloqué.
C'est vraiment incroyable.
Ça m'a permis de rassembler 23 ans de choses liées à l'ESPT
et au TCC,
au même endroit.
Ce n'était jamais arrivé avant.
Excusez-moi.
Melissa Walker : Au cours des cinq dernières années,
plus de 1 000 masques ont été créés.
C'est plutôt impressionnant, n'est-ce pas ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
J'aurais aimé partager ce processus avec mon grand-père,
mais je sais qu'il serait ravi
de savoir que l'on trouve des moyens
d'aider les militaires d'hier et de demain à guérir,
et de trouver les ressources en eux
auxquelles ils peuvent faire appel
pour se guérir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)